[Music]
if you wanted to drive you we gotta go
no I want personal chauffeur go okay
seriously dad Walken would have been
fine
breaking news spider-man saves the day I
guess spider-man this guy swings in once
the day zip zap zop dancing man you get
arrested guys don't cops run red lights
well some do but uh not your dad in your
universe there's only one spider-man but
there's another universe it looks this
sounds like yours but it's not my name
is Miles Morales
thank you you like me
I knew my day would come around this
time I know it's complicated sandy
customer
I don't know what happened to you I can
teach you to be spider-man hmm I love
this burger so delicious well the best
burgers I've ever had
you have money right I'm not very liquid
right now I think you're gonna be a bad
teacher how am I supposed to save the
whole world you can't think about saving
the world you have to think about saving
one person one thing I know for sure
don't do it like me do it like you
[Music]
cus to the sparking it's amazing paired
up whatever you choose to do it that
you'd agree
I love you miles you want to look at
this way I love you dad
I love you just like I thought when did
you teach me that I didn't it's a little
joke the team-building hey guys okay
who are you I'm Gwen Stacy come on how
many more spotty people are there same
as a comic-con what's coming
[Music]
[Applause]